hey everyone it's Mike and today is
Wednesday May 2nd and I just want to go
over a couple trades I took this morning
this was in the mini Dow right now it's
about 10 after 9 but I took these trades
you know basically between 7 & 8 more or
less let me just go back where am I here
find where these trades are okay so you
know it's quarter after 6:00 and we hit
this high we sold off and I was kicking
myself that I wasn't part of my screen
at this time but has been my laundry of
all things at that time and we sold off
we got a little bounce up here I really
felt you know we can come off from the
75 area down into the mid-60s or you
know even below that I end up I got
short at 73 right here you can see and I
got stopped out boom you know right away
I'm short market sells off to Dick's
rallies up stops me out okay I lost 11
ticks on that trade nice way to start
off the day and you know but I'm still
looking for or I'll say looking for a
reason to sell but you know I saw a
reason to sell in here with you know
that this is the order flows trader
software now basically gave me a sign
that you know what this there's still
some selling pressure in the market now
if you notice the Delta minus 20 minus
44 zero it's just coincidence that at 0
could be minus 1 t plus 1 just happen to
end up at 0 and this one Delta came in
quite strong minus 6 yeah and I'm
getting short at at 73 so basically you
know they're the same level that I was
at before and sort of the same thing
happened again we sold off down to you
know 67 I think it was then bounced back
up you know and this is bouncing back
and forth here and I don't like to be in
the markets that's at 7:30 it's just you
know going back to the time when I was
on the floor you know 7:30 always like
to be flat and I'm covering it right
right people have a 728 or something
like that and so you know is this a
three tick winner eventually you know
the market did sell-off but again you
know I'm still seeing signs in the order
flow that they're selling pressure in
the market you know that there are
potential trap traders that we're trying
to take the market higher
and they're sort of long and wrong and
I'm getting short here at 65
this was the move that I was looking for
to happen when I got short initially
here at 73 so I'm sure that's 65 and you
know the Delta comes in again minus 90
good - 125 good then this was - 9 I end
up covering it here at 44 and the market
sold off her sold off all the way down
to about was a 30 and you know it's just
a stupid mistake that I made you know I
I was using this this you know the chart
trader on that chart trader whatever you
call it on this ninja trader and I had
yeah I covered it and it actually
entered an ATM for me you know at 44
when I covered I bought it at 44 it's
doing a stop you know 10 ticks below so
I end up getting short here at 34 on a
mistake by time I realized it I just
covered it here at 31 you know that
that's not a trade that I would have
taken you know in this case it just
happened to work out as a profit but you
know usually they ended up usually they
end up being losers
setting up an ATM strategy and you know
it just automatically took it as when I
when I bought it to cover it through in
the ATM you know so that's why you gotta
keep an eye on your position tab in your
order book and I had one more quick
trade I'm just 42 o'clock you know I
felt we were putting in a nice little
bottom in here you know I'm seeing signs
here and the order flow so these green
arrows are telling me that there's
there's buying coming in here the
support of buying you know I see these
pointed controls all coming in down here
and you know this was a really quick hit
and I got in at 30 I thought I could
cover it at 40 but you know then my
phone started ringing and yeah I had to
take the call so I just I just covered
it here at 34 eventually you know I
didn't go all the way up to was at 44
but I mean it would've hit my target but
you know I I was expecting this call so
I just had to jump get out of the market
I don't want to be managing trading
while I'm doing something else but yeah
so where are we right now so we came
down here came down just above the
Lowe's you know ESPYs where you know our
lows for the day as a piece all right
here
let me just make this a little easier to
see you know are those for this and peas
are here at 62 and a half and it's SEC
here sorry resize these charts so you
know what we're well off off are those
we're good six points off our lows
Nasdaq again you know Nasdaq our lows
are way down here and this is a nice
trade I talked about in the inner circle
actually I haven't talked about it yet
but it's it's it's a video that I'm
putting together this is a great buying
opportunity these types of bars and you
know I hope to get these I got five
videos that I have to record and get up
in that inner circle for you guys but
you know this is a nice one from the
ninety-four area all the way up what
else we got
so anyway so Nasdaq is well up off our
lows our lows are actually bound around
sixty sixty six sixty six it's uh that's
my trade recap so you could see you know
it was a hundred bucks it's not like wow
you know I made thousands of dollars I'm
go out buy a Ferrari or not you know
what these were you know pre honest a
pre market but this was 7:00 to 8:00
a.m. this morning and you know it just
shows you you know you can trade these
markets I'll say any time of the day but
you know maybe tonight if I got some
free time I'll try and do some trading
and record it for you guys but you know
I I hope you appreciate this video and
look forward to the next ones thanks
everyone and have a great day bye-bye